how are you all doing today
game time please I want to start so
everyone can see this on camera I love
this movie so much I think you guys did
such a tremendous job and I really have
to single you out Shia for your
brilliant script who and I it's just so
beautiful what you shared I commend you
with all my heart I love I love this
script this is the nicest you've ever
been to me in in some of my 15 years
Stephen this is cuz it's such a good
movie I appreciate you man right um so I
have to jump backwards and start like
this is a very personal story you really
open up your heart how how tough was it
for you to finally decide hey I want to
share my story um well I I initially was
just sharing it with my buddy yeah so it
was initially just one buddy to another
buddy yeah we both create we're both
creators but it was never gonna be
necessarily a movie we had been chasing
a narrative but it initially started
just sharing notes sharing stories
because we have similar sensibilities
and we had sort of talked about these
things in the past and then it started
taking a shape as a narrative and was
encouraged by Alma to be a narrative and
the more she would encourage me the more
hopeful I felt about many things of
great many things but specifically my
immediate future and my my day-to-day
sense of hope
she had like thrown a mustard seed and
you know just like just stay on the
bright side of life like The Jungle Book
song and so so with her encouragement
and doing therapy sessions with Carrie
my therapist and and going to see my dad
this is how the we wrestled it into some
kind of shootable script then when she
went to edit it that all changed again
and she pretty much wrote a whole nother
script pretty much arranged that
reconstructed
how do you how did you decide where to
start the movie because there's a lot of
places but that opening moment is so
important to set everything up so how
did you decide where how you wanted to
start it yeah initially the script was
written more linear so it started with
no idea
hit with a pie in the face then going
through their whole story cut too you
know Lucas and the years that what
happened and then when I went to the
Edit and kind of saw the film assembled
it just didn't feel right then I felt
like knowing the consequences of what
happened to this kid before really going
backwards and also just staying loyal to
actually how it happened in many ways
because when you think about it you know
the way I have known that story is to
see Shia dealing with everything he was
dealing with and kind of losing a bit of
control of this whole thing and then
tracking back to saying hey this is what
happened and here's how it all went down
so just kind of actually going back to
that to the truth of it to how it
unfolded you know for the two of you
guys talked a little bit about how you
got ready for these roles and what is it
like on set working with someone who is
it's such a personal story you know what
I mean ladies first
[Music]
I'll take I'll take what I think it was
almost therapy for me to prepare for
this this role I took a lot of personal
stuff and I took a lot of the characters
personal stuff and I merged them
together wrote all his stuff so it was
personal for me as it was for him Noah
saying yeah yeah I mean for me it was
you know that most of this first bit you
know couldn't happen it couldn't be as
effective as it is without the
relationship and I guess chemistry
between Otis and his dad and Shia and
his dad and so just hanging out with
Shia I mean it's you know
spent annoying but you know how to hang
out with them and had to play got to
juggle with him and ya know but just
like you know care about us no more but
I actually want to want to the scenes
between the two of you you're you're
playing your father he's playing you it
is really tough to watch at times and
also you can you really feel this
dynamic between the two of you the love
yet the frustration and the desperation
that it all reads through and so talked
a little bit about finding you know
regardless of his tricky [ __ ] he's doing
now where there's a lot of love between
us and and a genuine real love as two
people not as like old time or a young
timer none of that I never treated him
like a kid he's always been my equal
he's a tremendously gifted dance partner
and I leaned on him a lot as much as he
got to know me through the manuscript
that I had given him and what he knew
about me I also got to know him a lot
and hung out with his folks and hung out
with his parents and hung out with him
and his siblings and saw how he gets
down with them and and integrated a lot
of that relationship between him and his
dad that I you know I met him at the
audition with him in his pop and I hit
my heart soon as I saw him I saw his dad
there I saw his dad before I saw him
gotta love my dad I do love your dad and
and I remember I saw his father first
and then I said well where's your kid at
and he said he's outside running lines
this is when I knew Noah was right I
went outside he was pacing with the
pages grinding like a like a like like
what I remember and usually when you see
like little kids in audition they're
like sitting there waiting for their
opportunity parents are like coddling
them this wasn't that relationship this
was like like dad knew process dad
respected process kid is outside
grinding and I thought oh what a great
intro and then when I came outside I
introduced myself and it wasn't there
was no starstruck nothing he didn't know
who I was at all from a hole in the wall
pretty much I think he'd seen a couple
videos about me but he was never an even
Stevens fan and I think
helped our relation is now but just
because I paid him to say that and also
because he was forced to watch a bunch
of stuff was like you better watch this
yeah but in the beginning we just met
each other is like dual down some dance
partners and we got by my truck and we
started grinding together and all mo
came out looking for me trying to get
this audition going and me and him were
already in the midst of the scene she
just came out pulled her phone out
started filming from behind this glass
door and then sort of entered a scene
that was already midway through and this
was the beginning of the three of us is
process it was the beginning of the film
and you just felt this this overarching
click like movie it just felt like all
right here's the team sure one of the
things no matter what movie you're
making no matter how much time and money
you have it's never enough time it's
never enough money you're always going
to be pushed to the limits so what every
filmmaker I've spoken to always says you
know we need more demons I am curious so
before you start filming what were you
most concerned about being able to
accomplish with the limitations that
were in front of you what was a it again
what were you nervous about being able
to accomplish with like the limitations
in front of you Wow
well I was I was really I guess a bit
ambitious of not just capturing the
incredible script Chai's handed me which
as you could see even though when he's
answering questions he could just take
you there in him and I felt like he took
me there when I read the script those
descriptions like little things from the
details of props to just the language
and things people say to each other and
the the subtext of everything they said
you know so just capturing that and
telling his story but at the same time
being a bit ambitious about also
capturing the world visually that I felt
he lived in as an actor from the big
films to the you know to the to the
motel at the edges of town
metaphorically
and just doing that in like you know
nineteen days or something we ended up
with 20 or 21 or something like that
because of insurance stuff but like that
was really how do you put all of that
into into the time you have and we ended
up having more time to prep than to
shoot so really I think the answer was
the prep and the way these guys really
prepped and spent time together for two
months like running through things and
juggling and playing with each other and
studying each other they walked into
that room with so much history and it's
it's amazing that they managed to do and
cover it so much dialogue in such a
short time and I'm still blown away by
it I was going to say for people that
are watching this that don't understand
filmmaking I mean to use an example on
like a big movie you could be shooting
for six months yes you can be shooting
for nine months yeah but so 20 days to
make a movie is like yeah I mean they do
TV shows in eight days oh yeah it's not
a lot of time yeah yeah and like again
like to pack in like explosions and car
accidents and all of those things it was
something that kind of was hard to make
that decision and that call to do that
because it did bite into time they could
have been in the motel having you know
more time to do dialogue and it was like
walking that balancing act of like
having some scope and telling some stuff
visually and not just through language
because I really do believe in you know
the visual language of cinema and then
finding enough time for them to to
really battle with the script which was
a beast you know and had so much to to
offer and and again like I think that
the crew that we had the support that we
have from people from back from even
Stevens to transformers to people that
worked with Shai over the years and
saying we heard about this movie we want
to come in we want to help we want to
make this impossible thing happen and
having such a crew and our
cinematographer
Natasha Breyer and just people that were
you know there with us making this
happen on an impossible schedule is what
made it happen for all you guys I would
imagine making this movie is going to be
something you're going to remember the
rest of your lives is there like a day
or two that like you know a fun story
you can
each share from the making of the movie
no was great at this no way
no go ahead you ready
I loved um the day with a jam shut up
the day that was probably the most like
this is really therapeutic day with for
me was I mean we were in this like the
car park behind the the motel and I just
got to smash [ __ ] up and like you know
just beat up cars and like go around
picking up things and almost following
me with this camera and you know I was
just I was just playing around in this
in this place and I had all of this
anger and love and emotion and it just
all that came out within physically and
I loved that day I thought was very
beautiful Nasim oh thank you you're okay
you can't just roll with the sincerity
for just five seconds to this interview
for crying out loud I remember looking
at the pool and I'm looking around and
all the extras are like like they bout
to die and I'm cold
and I look over at Martin Starr and he
you know my star got that calm look on
his face oh man cold oh man he's that
he's an actor actor right there
and I was like I wonder what the people
in Dunkirk went through and all these
thoughts getting lost in it as I'm
shivering and I'm like I see why it's
not a lot of black people in these veils
I ain't even got a little lotion like
you know just the things that you know
normal thoughts that happen and then at
one point I'm wearing a robe and I'm and
I'm I'm on the grounds of this facility
and I just walk off and it's like a
hiking trail and stuff in the woods and
it's hikers we're hiking gear on and I'm
in a robe
and and I don't know where we were in
the city where they looking at me like
oh hey go one of those crazy people
yeah and I didn't play it down I'm just
like hey what are y'all doing that's
nice day today huh you know saying all
this stuff weirdos say so yeah I have a
few that happened I wasn't even there
that long but it's a few of these
stories of me that were that were that
stick out to me when it comes to this
you know this film me Shia for the first
time and then I always a crazy one ya
know a gentler January like nothin no
hate or anything here like genuinely
yeah it always is like it's out of
anyone that I've ever met like the first
time Shia is the coolest first time meet
that you'll have like he's always like
cuz he's so you know he's not awkward at
all and you just he's just so truthful
and you know there's no he doesn't
[ __ ] you or anything like that it's
just straight to the point and it's just
you know he's just pretty fun to be
around so yeah and my he just walked up
on me before I knew it man nice thank
you you being here man thank you for
being here shyah shyah and then he was
gone and I was like did I just I just
met him and all the questions started
after that yeah and I was like well he's
gone I can't even ask him or say thank
you for even having me here it was he
was there and gone that fast you've been
bit by a mosquito you don't realize you
been to a mosquito do you start itching
oh yeah I think I got bit by a mosquito
it was that I think I just met Shia
those are some really good stories yeah
it's really hard I loved I really got a
kick out of blowing up Lucas that was
really fun you know I'm just like I
somebody that comes from documentaries
and stuff like that it was really nice
to play Michael Michael Bay for a day
and we did it in like one take so it was
really cool just like orchestrating this
thing and we heard
doing all these things that are so
technical and then just seeing it
everybody screaming when we did it I
don't think any of us has ever done it
before on this guru most of us anyway I
mean the core that helped us did but I
just mean like you know me and like the
the production designer and we we were
just like in Chris went producer we were
just like kids by the monitor watching
this and we were just like wow I can't
believe some people play like that every
day this is crazy you have some really
as you said earlier you have some very
technical shots yeah for such a limited
time form I actually want to ask you
there's a shot of the motorcycle coming
out of the parking lot I think oh yeah
and it's like in your maneuvering but
there's two cars coming and you have to
maneuver around that and I'm like that's
a very tricky shot for such a short why
he's done everything though you know for
him that was just like that's like a
walk in the park but like I mean people
yeah I mean he's he's done all of those
things I was just like a new to that but
you you've done what have you not done
you've been living on these you've been
living on these harnesses for years well
if you don't mind talk about that one
shot that like did you have more than
one take or you're like let's just do it
and move on no that one we had like two
or three takes I think we did yeah yeah
yeah it was like kind of a stunt effort
with a few people and one thing stoves
usually like like the big explosion or
big explosion yes it takes I would
either be big explosions yeah that's so
true
that's not sure we had a few of those no
microwave do more taste in that and we
did oh yeah I've seen him do more than
then he he is what we call a lot of time
and money when he does his stuff I am
curious about the editing room though
because that's the final rewrite you
touched on how things changed I'm
curious how long was your first cut
compared to the finished film um
she's always been dead set on keeping it
under 90 minutes true yeah all my films
have been under 90 minutes I really I
really love that length I just don't
need to go longer than that so it was it
was really about that the first one too
but there was a few scenes that were
hard to cut out there was one really big
scene that was probably one of the
biggest things
biggest moments you know like to decide
on which was the scene between Shia and
Lucas which you kind of don't see we
lost it in the film because we went
nonlinear and that scene I think to
shoot it was it was a huge huge day for
us emotionally and one of the diseases
we rehearsed more than anything in the
process of prep and then making the
decision to remove that was a big moment
and then you know she has just been so
cool that we only literally came at the
end and I showed him the cut and he's
never been attached to anything I was
always feeling so conscious of cutting
certain things you know that were hard
to make or that required like the actors
to go somewhere so deep or painful but
that's that's what you're doing the Edit
I mean I think you're just kind of you
know you have to sacrifice certain
things and you have to just like figure
out what's the what's the best for the
film and find it go with it so what was
if you don't mind me asking what was the
last thing you cut out before you
picture locked
I think the last thing that I did that
was the most I guess interesting in
terms of changing things was actually
cutting not out but cutting in like I
guess it's cutting the opening sequence
which is really that whole opening
sequence of OTUs getting lost in this
whole world of reality and cinema was
something that I've literally cut a few
days before before we locked the film
kind of had the idea to add that opening
and I think you came and saw it you saw
a cut without it and then you saw the
lock cut and it had it in it and that
was like a massive you know sort of
changed to the cut to add suddenly a
whole opening sequence last-minute I was
gonna say that opening scene really
throws you into the world yeah I don't
know I I love the opening and I can't
imagine it not being like that do you
know what I mean yeah but it didn't have
it like for probably like four or five
months it was without it and then like
literally the last like four days before
we locked the cut I found it it's crazy
it's just it also just I mean so many
people just pass over editing they don't
understand
you know the significance of yeah of
course and like cutting like
performances and all of those things
like it was it was quite beautiful to
see because you really get to kind of
dive into the details of what your
actors do on set that you you don't
necessarily I mean you track a lot of
things in the monitor but really only
when you're in the editing you realize
their brilliance of what of what they
did you know I actually want to ask you
guys I I am curious you guys really put
your heart and soul on screen what was
it like for each of you seeing the
finished film for the first time and
have you ever with anything you've done
ever done and said I really got to talk
to the director I know my take on take
three was better well they're not like
that I mean I've never been in an
editing room but like I've heard a lot
about it and it's a whole nother world
like it's a whole nother thing and I and
usually you know if I'm doing a movie
with the director I don't trust I
shouldn't be doing that movie so and you
know so when I do these these these
rumors I think it's all I do these these
scenes and I do these takes I'll trust
that they'll find the most truthful one
the the best one so when I see the movie
it's you know there's no changing it but
but like you know with this one I was
you know blown away and I honestly
couldn't remember anything I did that's
the funny thing it was just like it this
movie was such a blur and just such like
a kind of I always say and Lucas as well
we have the same thing that it's kind of
feels like someone's just press
fast-forward and any all guys like
really quickly it just like kind of
mashes together but you know like I
remember the experience and I loved the
experience but just to kind of I see it
and I'm like wow that's that's Otis
that's that's not me so it's it and
that's the thing when people people
always ask me is it weird watching
yourself and I'm like I'm not watching
myself that's a different person up
there
I mean I guess it's a version of myself
but it's like you know it's I'm not what
if I was watching myself I would not be
watching that movie because I cringe
when I watch myself that's a very good
answer
I'm similar I'm similar I'm but I'm more
I'm less confident so when the director
is like good I'm always like yeah we
moving on and I'm still standing there
cameras are going and I'm just in bed
like was that snore okay but I'm like
him except I don't know what happened
when action happens like after she says
action and took cut that's why
everything I remember is after after
that because to me it's like a dance
like I'm present and long as I'm present
I'm not watching what's going on I'm
like there with the person I'm talking
to sure so what do you think about when
you finally saw it when I finally saw
the movie what I think about the movie
you know well I think that's what I
originally asked and also have you ever
gone in the editing room and been like
negotiating like I think the other take
was better or never no I never won in
the editing room that's her that's where
she plays jazz that was Alma Alma's
almost you know starts I think I think
her coming from documentaries that's
such a singular editing process and her
film specifically Bombay Beach was quite
a singular film this is a person who
shot to sound did everything on that
movie and then went into the editing
room with you know thousands of hours of
footage and went found the movie so I
knew this she's very she's most
confident in an editing room of all the
filmmaking chapters editing is where she
turns on that's for superhero mode so I
didn't want to get involved in there
because I knew that that was gonna be a
very singular thing even though she had
help and had people in there who were
who were on the same way yeah
and Dominique Lapierre and Monica
Salazar who edited this film with me but
really we were all surprised in the
editing room when Shia came because we
were expecting Shia is so specific onset
and has such a sense of what he wants to
convey and when he thinks he had a good
take or not he really knows at the end
of it each take if he you know if he got
it or not he's not unsure of that so I
didn't know if like when he comes to the
editing room what to expect and we've
never made a film like this together so
I was prepared for anything and really
it was quite incredible and quite
beautiful to see his emotional reaction
to the cut as opposed to you know we
were ready to get notes it was like no
notes and he was just kind of crying I
think the first time he saw it and we
spent Linc pretty much 20 minutes mostly
hugging and just we were all celebrating
four days afterwards in the editing room
first question - right there completely
I was show about the doing comedy sets
at the Comedy Store so talk in the
morning she would be there I always
sleep and is editing for those I'll know
is like play cut stop go back erase the
bling wait stop go back so I was like to
use that for like hours yeah completely
I have to stop there
because you guys have to do other things
called other interviews I just want to
say again how much I love this movie and
I really hope everyone who's watching
this thank you thanks seriously it's
it's fantastic